TO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOR
PURPOSES OF ESTABLISHING A
QUORUM [inaudible]
JACKSON.
GORGEOUS.
ALAN.
COPYRIGHT.
COPYRIGHT HERE JONES.
JONES HERE MORNING HERE MORNING
HERE STERN.
STERN HERE AMBER.
AMBER HERE WHY CASKEY HERE WHITE
HOUSE HERE.
CORN IS ESTABLISHED. EIGHT
MEMBERS WERE GATHERED DUE -- TO
JUST REALLY A RECORDING ERROR
FROM OUR MEETING EARLIER THIS
WEEK -- RESPECTING SENATE BILL --
ONE FORTY TWO WE NEED.
A MOTION TO RECONSIDER SENATE
BILL ONE FORTY TWO IS THERE A
MOTION.
ALTHOUGH.
I HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI FOR
RECONSIDERATION.
WILL THIS RECORDING SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
MOTION FOR RECONSIDERATION ON
SENATE BILL [inaudible]
ONE FORTY TWO JACKSON
[inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
ALAN.
COPYRIGHT HI COPYRIGHT I JONES
JONES I AM MORNING.
MORNING I STERN.
STERN I NUMBERED.
NUMBERED I LIKE HUSKY HI MY
CASKEY I OKAY THAT MOTION PASSES.
SIX TWO ZERO NOW ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON SENATE BILL ONE FORTY
TWO THIS WOULD BE A MOTION -- TO
PASS. TO THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING WITH THE AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE DETAILED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS.
I'D ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
I HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI.
SENATE BILL ONE FORTY TWO TO
PASS THE COMMITTEE ON HOUSING
WITH THE AMENDMENTS DETAILED IN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WITH THE
RECORDING SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON THE MOTION.
THE MOTION IS TWO PASSES AMENDED
TO SENATE HOUSING.
JACKSON.
GORGEOUS.
ALLEN.
ALLEN I COVER EURO.
CUP HERO I'D JONES.
JONES NO MONEY HI MORNING ICE
STERN.
STERN I AMBERG.
UMBERG HIGHWAY CASKEY.
I CASKEY I AND THAT HAS A SEVEN
TO ONE VOTE THE MOTION CARRIES.
THE BILL IS OUT MEMBERS THAT
CONCLUDES THE NEXT ONE I'M SORRY
SIX TO ONE THE REORD WILL
REFLECT IT.
TO SIX TO ONE VOTE THE MOTION IS
OUT THE BILL IS OUT THIS
CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS OF SENATE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY WERE
TURNED THANK YOU MEMBERS.
ARE ALL.
YEAH ONLY WHEN YOU'RE HERE